Don't be fooled.
These gruesome burn
wounds are actually fake.
Creating effects like
this for TV and movies
is a rigorous, time-consuming process
that involves complex
prosthetics and makeup,
some of which are actually lit on fire,
and a close attention to detail,
but the result is worth the wait.
Daenerys: Dracarys!
Narrator: When a director
needs a character
who's been lit on fire,
or maybe the victim
of a chemical spill or explosion,
they'll go to someone like Ben Bornstein,
a special makeup effects artist
who runs Taking Shape Studio.
Bornstein has done all sorts
of special makeup effects work
on movies like "The
Departed" and "The Fighter,"
and he's done several types of burn wounds
for shows like "Blindspot" and "Gotham."
Bornstein brought in stunt
performer Kachina Dechert
to undergo this transformation.
Any good Hollywood makeup artist knows
that the actor's comfort is crucial.
Ben Bornstein: How can
we make it nice for them
and not as crazy and disruptive
to their performance?
Our job is to enhance their performance.
Narrator: And that can be done
without sacrificing realism.
The first step for
Bornstein is figuring out
what kind of burn it is
and what the damage should look like.
In a hypothetical scenario
for this demonstration,
the character has escaped
a burning building,
but not unscathed.
This is a fresh burn
wound, and the character
hasn't had a chance to
seek medical attention.
Bornstein: There's all these
things that go in the story
that we have to think
about, from step A to Z.
So, say, like, you got burned
by an iron on your face,
like a curling iron.
You gotta think, how hot was it?
How long was it on?
How long did it sit in your face?
We gotta think about the reality of it.
Would the skin bubble?
Would it come off with the iron?
Would it be a piece?
I want this to look like she
just got out of an explosion.
Narrator: There are some cheap, easy ways
for Bornstein to go about this,
methods he would call "out of the kit."
For a burned arm, he can
use a burn transfer tattoo.
Bornstein: It's kinda
like a Bazooka Joe tattoo
you'd get when you're a kid,
but on steroids that lasts all day.
Narrator: These are
great for makeup artists.
They stay on all day and
need minimal touch-ups.
One of the toughest parts
of a makeup artist's job
is making sure the cast looks exactly
the same on every single day.
This method is great for continuity.
While efficient, these
tattoos are two dimensional,
so they work better for
background characters.
Another easy and effective method:
using Glatzan bald-cap
plastic, aka Baldiez,
and actually lighting it on fire.
There are plenty of ways
to make simple materials look gruesome.
Bornstein: So, now I'm
just cutting a sheet
of bald cap vinyl,
and it's gonna make a
little weird gross membrane
on top of the burn that Adam's painting.
So, we'll just glue this on,
and we'll blend with the edge
and have K-Y Jelly
inside the middle of it,
so we can see some depth and translucency
to give it more of an effect.
Narrator: Bornstein can
and will go much bigger
for a scenario like this.
After all, this is supposed
to be a hero character,
another term for the main character.
So Bornstein and his team made
some large prosthetic pieces.
Before starting on them, he
needed to do some research
so he could nail down a few key things,
texture and color.
That research can take strange forms,
like looking at pictures of burnt meat.
Bornstein: The textures are
cool, but it's not, you know,
it's not there.
Look at this, dude.
This is what I was talking about.
It's gorgeous.
Look at that detail. Look at those colors.
If you could see, all the black
are really the only raised areas here.
So, we're looking at
what could be a piece,
or even just, like,
maybe the Baldiez stuff
that we put on top of just paint.
All this little fatty area
and, like, all the yellow,
golden yellow, I love all that.
And to really notice that
the edges aren't black.
It's the deepest parts of it are black.
Like, if you look at, this
is just black little spots.
And then there's a ring of red,
and then there's black way above it.
We could almost even probably use
some of her tones in there.
But I love this picture for reference.
I think it's beautiful.
Narrator: You can see that influence
in the prosthetic pieces.
Look at all the cracks and char
and the dominance of red and black.
Like with any prostheses,
it started with a head cast.
Bornstein used that cast
to create a sculpture
of Dechert's head.
From there, they got a
plaster version of her head
and a rubber mold negative.
That negative was used to
build the silicone pieces.
His team sculpted away to
get the perfect texture.
While working, they had to keep in mind
that this was supposed to be a fresh burn
as opposed to an aged scar.
Bornstein: Like, it just happened,
and she's still smoldering,
but she's put out.
Narrator: Prostheses like
this are needed especially
if there is going to be
a lot of close-up shots
of a burned character.
Bornstein: You can't fake that.
You need the textures there.
Narrator: Everything had to fit
and be blended in perfectly
and follow the right color palette
so it looked like a truly fresh char.
The team also had to
build around her wardrobe.
They knew what costume she would wear
and that it would be
torn up by the explosion.
While they didn't have to make prostheses
for her entire body,
they did need to decide
if there would be visible wounds in areas
where skin was exposed.
If there were open areas left blank
where there should be a burn,
it would make the overall
performance less convincing.
Bornstein: We'll glue this to
her, and maybe we'll fuse it
with an appliance or something.
Here's the boot line. That's good.
We're gonna do a number on you, Kachina.
Gonna be dope.
Narrator: Hair was just as much a factor.
Bornstein: I want the piece
to lay flat with the edge.
We'll blend the edge, then
the hair will go over it.
So, all of this hair has to go this way.
Narrator: To maximize
comfort for the star,
they saved some of the least comfortable
prosthetic pieces for last.
They started early by gluing
on the big chest piece.
Blending it into the skin is key.
This scaly piece could have
been placed on Dechert's leg,
but the team decided it
made more sense on her arm.
Bornstein: I love the little black.
And these little edges we
should paint black too.
I love that.
Narrator: And remember
those burned-up sheets?
They were put on alongside
the two prosthetic pieces,
layered and blended in,
so sometimes it was hard to tell
the difference between the two.
They decided to rely more heavily
on the burned plastics for her legs
while sticking to the color palette
and directly painting on
yellow wherever they could.
Bornstein: So, I see a big hole.
We're gonna paint that.
Narrator: Then this massive piece
went right on Dechert's stomach.
Notice how the edges were peeled off
and the piece was blended into her skin.
The final prosthetic piece they
attached was the face piece,
which only covered the left half.
Bornstein: This was most
of the meat of the build,
was making this piece.
Her ear will come through
this, and then I think
we'll put a black char to connect it.
Narrator: While they
could have covered the ear
to make it look like it fell off,
Bornstein thought it would
have been too obvious
and instead liked the
idea of keeping it on
but dirtying it up.
He also had to consider that the eyebrow
would have been burned off,
so Bornstein simply painted over it
so it wouldn't show up
under the face piece.
There are lots of
different final touch-ups
to make sure they looked
as fresh as possible.
Narrator: Other materials,
like "clean dirt,"
added to the color palette.
The final piece was also
the most uncomfortable:
contact lenses.
This stage required a lens technician.
In the end, everything was
so well blended together,
it's hard to tell what's
paint and what's silicone.
The real winner of the day?
Bornstein: I think it was,
honestly, the Glatzan sheets
that we put on her.
It really did sell it.
I wanted to mix kind of that reality
with, like, some superhero look
where half her head and hair is missing.
The fact that we decided
to take the sculpture
up into the hairline.
'Cause if it was just here,
it just doesn't look right.
So we wanted to go, like, the extra mile
and have it wrap around her head.
Narrator: Applying the
makeup to taking it all off
took over four hours.
Computers and visual effects have enhanced
the work of makeup and
special effects artists.
Bornstein: If you marry the two,
we can, like, recess crazy areas
of the face or body that
we can't do with makeup.
We'd have to make a fake head of it.
Narrator: So, why didn't Bornstein
and his team just create
the burns using CGI?
Especially when, as is
the case of Two-Face
in "The Dark Night," the
minimal practical makeup
might just be covered in a CGI layer?
Because practical effects
won't just give you
a better movie, but also
a better performance.
Bornstein: We can bring
something to the table
that looks organic, that looks real
and enhance the actor's performance.
If they have nothing on them,
maybe they won't emote as much.
Maybe they're laying in a hospital bed
and they're looking at their hand.
Maybe that will help
them cry more on camera.
We're giving them tools to work
with, but most importantly,
we're giving the camera tools to work with
so they don't have to
do it in postproduction.